any new merch
oh uh well yeah funny you ask
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and it's
june which means it's another month
which means it's time for another
questions and answer session and yes
there is new merch and this time it is
actually a limited edition but for good
reason so our good friends over at
cotton bureau who run the store and who
run a bunch of other stores are
celebrating their fifth birthday this
week and in honor of that they're going
to be doing giveaways the way this works
is basically as much stuff as they sell
on all of their sites including the
mkbhd shop the more and more extravagant
apple related giveaways they will be
doing so we're going to start with stuff
like airpods and apple tvs but with more
sales they'll work up to stuff like ipad
pros and imac so basically you can place
an order of the new merch this week
which is of course a nice little apple
inspired colored drawing although on the
site we're going to be calling it the
mkbhd special edition six colors shirt
apple please don't sue me and just for
good measure we'll also toss in the
clean original best-selling logo tee so
it's these two shirts in the drop this
week only shop away and good luck
all right on your questions so it turns
out a lot of the questions are about hot
ones yes i was on hot ones one of my
favorite youtube shows ever uh it is
live i'll link it below you can check it
out it was kind of amazing some of the
most common questions were one are the
wings really all that hot yes of course
they were actually that hot do you see
these tears in my eyes these are real
tears they don't just happen by eating
chicken wings and number two would be
just how was the interview itself and i
mean of course it was awesome shawn's a
great interviewer the show is awesome
but just like the amount of research
they do and the quality of questions i
don't think i've seen an episode in the
last like entire season where the guest
doesn't go
oh that's a that's a really good
question you know and then number three
is just like how long did it take you to
feel normal again which i would say if
you're asking about my face it would
probably be like half an hour before my
face stopped burning and if you're
asking about the rest of me i
i was fine overall though it's a really
awesome format and i think maybe in the
future we'll be able to actually i mean
since it's a youtube show collaborate
with sean and maybe do a sort of a like
a behind the scenes of hot ones i think
that would be a cool idea but let me
know what you guys think sam wants to
know got any new bangers you just want
to share or still listen to primadonna
well first of all sam yes i am still
listening to primadonna because it's a
great song
but i just want to toss out there i've
been like rediscovering or re-listening
to a bunch of overwork great artists
he's from canada reps it well
just overall awesome style
and staff has some thoughts on instagram
tv or ig tv as do a lot of people uh
thoughts on people repurposing the same
youtube videos for igtv
and it's it's kind of like in this weird
place where that's
sort of all people know how to do i mean
igtv is brand new so it's a platform
where people are figuring out how
figuring out content strategy at this
point and it's a boring thing to talk
about but you got to think about if you
want to make your own original content
just for igtv or if you don't really
have the resources to do that yet in
which case you just sort of put your
youtube videos on igtv i'm not the
biggest fan of that but i can see why
people do it because it's so easy what
i'm not a fan of is what i tweeted what
gopro did which is literally
you don't have to do this but they feel
obligated to use igtv so they just
re-uploaded a regular sideways video
with massive borders
in vertical
no point in doing that
absolutely no point in doing that so
while igtv is this young we're just kind
of figuring out what we want to do with
it the latest video i just uploaded is a
sort of a behind the scenes look some
never before seen clips behind the
scenes of auto focus episode two so when
we shot that aventador down in palm
beach none of the clips you see on igtv
are anywhere else so i think that's a
fun way to share stuff artie says do you
actually think igtv will be a serious
youtube competitor or was that first
video like a sponsored thing
oh what no i guess the first reaction to
like if i like something and they don't
like it then it must be sponsored it's
that was just me just talking about how
i feel as a matter of fact for the sake
of transparency here is a list of all of
the sponsored videos i've done on the
channel in the last 12 months so the
last year
those the only two ones dbrand is a
channel sponsor so shout out to them for
being a long-term supporter of the
videos we're able to make and then red
it's probably not the video you're
thinking of but about 10 months ago
there was a sponsored video as we
disclosed about the the red raven kit
when it came out and was first available
for shooting on youtube so that's it
it's not like having sponsors is a bad
thing but just for the sake of
transparency there it is jason says do
you think youtube should add a vertical
video section
for mobile only to compete with igtv
huh actually well no i don't think they
have to do that as a matter of fact a
lot of people don't know youtube
actually supports and has supported for
a while native vertical video a lot of
people don't know if you watch a native
vertical video on youtube and you full
screen it it full screens the same way
it does on instagram so igtv native
support isn't anything special or
something youtube doesn't have but it's
something worth noting so i don't even
really think that vertical video support
is a feature of instagram tv as much as
it's sort of a focus of what they're
driving people to make face it igtv is
not nearly a competitor to youtube not
even to vimeo or dailymotion at least
not until they implement horizontal
video all right hot take ready for this
i don't think
vertical video is that bad and hear me
out i think people are hating on
vertical video because that's
all they know how to do at this point
like obviously the logic makes sense
every camera shoots in widescreen every
tv every screen you look at behind me in
front of you it's all widescreen our
eyes are sideways this is how we watch
video but it's sort of like a chicken
and egg thing we watch video this way
because we make video this way and we
make video this way because we watch
video this way but the rise of things
like snapchat and instagram stories and
all of us holding our phones up like
this has kind of started this new thing
as much as you might hate seeing someone
make a vertical video and then upload it
to youtube where it has those sideways
bars a lot of people are just sharing it
with other people watching on their
phones and that's sort of a native
organic experience where you're just
watching it as if you captured it on
your phone so vertical video on phones
specifically is a thing that i'm not mad
at there's no black bars there's no
inefficiencies it fills up your whole
screen and the challenge now is just to
get creative about how to actually use
vertical video on your phone so i think
hating on vertical video just because
it's vertical is getting a little stale
it's getting a little old i think you
just got to start thinking a little bit
forward and getting creative and if
you're too bored to shoot vertical then
don't but we'll be on that train all
right thoughts on the rise of gaming
smartphones and it's kind of hard to say
a rise of gaming smartphones when
there's not that many i mean the
prominent ones are the razer phone and
we just got that new asus gaming phone
and there's some new ones coming up but
i like the genre i like the idea
especially in this world where we're
getting all these these fronts of phones
that are all these like featureless
fully screen no bezel no notch if they
all look the same on the front you kind
of lose some character that way so the
one thing i see these gaming phones
preserving is front-facing speakers like
big thick batteries like things that
make it a good media experience that you
kind of lose out on have you met viewers
or subscribers wearing your fire merch
ps i got some of course and love the
shirts thank you robert i'm glad you do
and yeah actually i have seen that um
lately or the most recently was actually
in toronto playing an ultimate game uh
which i tweet out every time we have a
game by the way a couple people were
wearing the shirt in the stands after
the game came down took some photos it
was fun so i have actually seen people
in the wild with the shirts on where
will lebron go
um
i don't know if i does lebron even know
where lebron's gonna go what happened to
the video with stephen curry oh yeah
that also was pretty recent so i posted
this photo not too long ago uh i did a
little bit of a shoot uh commercial
shoot actually with steph curry steph's
coming out with a new shoe the curry
five and we made like a sort of a
commercial under armour reached out and
they're like hey do you want to be in
this commercial with steph
playing yourself
i was like yeah that sounds awesome so
we were out there for a day with that uh
the commercial i'll link that below as
well but yeah it's just kind of a sort
of a fun thing it's not a youtube collab
really it's just kind of a fun
opportunity that i happen to meet steph
at
hey marquez tell them what's under the
hood
for version five we studied all the
previous iterations
are you and victor oladipo related
because y'all
look
just alike
do we though
like do we really
actually though like are you
are you just saying that or do you
really think we look alike really have
you considered podcasting as well
uh yeah i've i've considered i've tossed
around the idea of podcasting actually
but
as far as like formats go i think
podcasting is a very different skill
like that's something not a lot of
people consider about these different
platforms people who can be really good
at youtube videos you know four or five
minute videos
doing
live stuff on twitch like that is a
completely separate different
entertainment skill being good in an
hour-long podcast just talking about
random stuff rambling maybe that's a
totally separate different skill even
making igtv videos or instagram videos
just short form comedy stuff that's
another different skill so i've thought
about podcasting but i don't actually
think i'd be that good at it but i still
play with the idea i think it could be
fun to have like an experimental format
to just talk about tech and give
opinions when i might not put that all
in videos would you guys be into a mkbhd
podcast of some sort audio only video
and audio something like that guess let
me know and captain shadow says if you
had a chance to interview elon musk what
are the questions that you would
definitely ask
you know what i'm actually gonna i'm
gonna flip that one right back around at
you let's let's say uh let's say i have
an opportunity to do that let's say i
might tweet at him and he gets back at
me
what questions
should i
or would i
ask elon
we could talk tech we could talk cars we
could probably talk whatever but i'm
curious what you would say i'll be
hanging out in the comments below
probably taking notes
either way
that's been it for the june q a thanks
for watching that also rhymed talk to
you in the next one
peace